oh this is very much the achy older self
oh i thought so they just wheeled your
walker over there yeah i know he's uh i
i also have the younger stuff he's also
named walker so we've done double
entendre there
[Music]
yeah yeah that is true if you have the
ability and i got to add i really did
enjoy this ride it's a fun adventure and
a good follow-up to free guy i think so
too it's fun to make big original movies
um that doesn't happen every day so you
know i'm really grateful i got to do
this with sean levy who i did free guy
with as well and
you know netflix has just been all in
since day one and it's it's been a lot
of fun well good another good ride here
so if you had the ability in the spirit
of the adam project would you go back
and visit yourself as your younger self
or your older son i think i think i
would go see my older self i'd be more
curious to see what the future holds
than the past
i mean the past you'd spend so much time
dealing with so many things that are
broken
or wrong i i think the the future just
sort of see if something landed right
yeah you know i'm sure you're not fair
enough
uh how's your parenting style landon
these days we see jen's character you
know she's wanting to emphasize to her
child
do the right thing now it's all
pertaining to your future so what's your
parental style like are you that kind of
dad he wants the girls to like have good
behavior make all the good grades really
think about your future right now well i
mean i think i would be
a psychotic if i didn't want my children
to at least you know
try to do something you know right and
with integrity um you know focused a
little bit more on that i think then
you know my kids are seven five and two
i'm not like you gotta get better grades
i mean
i'm like i don't it doesn't matter you
pee you know you got aces yeah exactly
no i'm just happy if they finish a bowl
of cereal
what is yours and blake's parental style
like uh i don't know i would say
probably like a brown belt at this point
i don't know work working up the chain
of command
this movie screams sequel
so are you in for more
no i think this is a one of one and i
think that that's a really nice thing to
do i think it's one of one right well
yeah i don't think that i don't know why
you i don't think we need to have a
sequel for everything i think it's okay
to just do a movie
and that's sort of what we intended here
i don't think any we've never had a
discussion about a sequel we've got to
continue this trifecta finish the
trifecta with you and sean levy now that
you've worked together on free guy the
adam project exactly so what's next for
the team uh we are working on uh three
different things believe it or not no
yes are you being for real i'm being
dead serious sometimes i have the word
gullible no no no that's fine um you
know i have a tendency to be a little uh
you know
on occasion but but no no we are working
on three different uh three different
projects right now yeah you guys find
that this works well together we work
very well together and i'm very grateful
for that